[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the public
space we were supposed to have been
gathered tonight to talk about communism
but he is not responsive by email I'm
sure you will join us at some point in
the night maybe as some technical
difficulties but the news are so insane
that I thought look I cannot stop the
beginning of this show how did I get the
vision to leave biology to become a
broadcast news and Alice analyst I have
no idea but it was a genius move we are
sitting on only gold mind of news and so
let's get started but we have a as a
reminder to our audience join entropy
this is my favorite platform for super
chats because they give a good read and
they don't take your money like YouTube
so it's a great place to send me
donations and questions you can also
send questions for free and you can also
participate to our survey of tonight do
you think this relationship had a causal
role in the shooting today we are
getting a text from the ex-girlfriend of
the Dayton shooter and all of my
predictions are a beard there are they
are proven true I've often said that
polyamorous relationships are extremely
dangerous that the the masculine
psychology is not able to end all this
and I think that because of the jealousy
aspect and I think that the data and
shooting case may have been caused much
more than we originally thought by this
kind of circumstance now as I'm saying
this to you guys I see that our friend
bill gayde as connected and bill we are
live how are you doing bill
I was but I can't see you I only see
your photograph all right you won't be
able to see the video tonight because
Google as disable this feature
unfortunately and I didn't find yet a
way to send to the guests the video but
I can assure you that we're seeing you
and the crowd is also seeing me it's
just a problem with Google right now so
uh bill gayde we've been discussing
communism and I've been complaining
against communism and we thought it
would be a great time to talk about your
experience with communism my
understanding is that you fled communism
you left the u.s. well we gotta start at
square one how first I entered communism
you know and I was in there for over 20
years you know since the age of 15 I
started very early okay but you movement
you were in a Marxist movement of some
kind well again you know when I was
about 15 years old I was reading a lot
of stuff very early for my age and I
read a lot of Marx Lenin etc and by the
age of twenty twenty-one there abouts I
don't remember exactly I was invited to
join the Communist Party of Argentina
and I did join and we had a little group
a little urban guerrilla and we were
planning on doing operations Oh Paris
okay like like changing the world
well like killing people
oh wow we can we cannot appeal for
violence here and so bill get is is
saying this as a descriptive statement
about is fast and of course it is
nothing appeal to today's action alright
no obviously the things have changed a
lot if you look at you know that second
picture I sent you there I don't have
you received all those pictures oh let
me check I don't think I did
send them by email yeah I sent them by
email if you look there's a second
picture there and that's the guy follow
it in the picture next to shows how he
ended up in those days it was pretty uh
pretty heavy stuff okay when you say the
second picture is it cool Kuban top or
dirty well no you see vertical send to
each other you don't see him I sent you
a picture 'he's ICL crazy Jay extinction
paper on Kong yeah all the pictures okay
there they are oh okay I would not be
showing this to the audience but this is
a man whose face has been completely
scraped off and scratched by some
phenomenon of my violence bullets okay
so you were a friend with this guy no no
I never knew him but he had your
organization called Teresita
revolutionary other what is it people's
People's Army revolutionary arm oh yeah
that's always a communist I throw their
stuff yeah yeah he was he was a
communist by far and the left side you
see how he was in the right side you see
how he ended up with the group of
military caught up with him you know and
he shot up there yeah the bullets
totally changes looking yeah yeah he was
he was the first guy to die and so was
the captain that went together they all
shine each other in a room essentially
they were shooting each other as
communists they were all communists that
was an internal fight or an external no
no what happened was what happened was
the these guys were trying to get to
Cuba and they were by the way connector
and this cord off here absolutely you
can okay because I get all this
interruption for these okay and so what
happened they were trying to get to Cuba
and they were spotted or somehow
a military patrol heard about them and
they went to this place like 10 guys and
he caught these guerrillas in there and
there were like eight of them and it was
just a shootout in a room it's like they
opened the door and everybody just began
began shooting at each other and the
first guy to die cause I'm - Joe and the
first guy to die and the military's I
was the guy the captain who was running
them adorable so he became a martyr well
but I feel I'll smile suddenly because I
was about to share my experience with
communism which was to be a Marxist for
one year and arguing at the dinner table
with my father about how the world was
unjust to minorities you're taking it to
the next level you are talking about
communist mobsters yeah yeah yeah I'm
talking about real stuff because this
was real stuff you know in the 74 there
abouts 1974 yeah you know in my where I
lived there were you could hear shots
every night every night seven when he
was there every night it was shootouts
between the police and guru and urban
guerrillas and ago just movement the gun
store at a communist order a kind of
revolutionary action in Argentina yeah
there was a very grassroots movement to
overthrow the government of bid on and
they don't had died his wife who was the
vice president became the president and
she was really no good and so the
military wanted around the workers
wanted or everybody wanted her out and
the military you know made a coup
vanilla and he started what is known as
the dirty war lasted many years and
during that time I left Argentina and
then later on I found out what they did
you know with a lot of people they
tortured them they they killed a lot of
women who were pregnant they took their
babies they gave him the military a big
mess and I missed all that you miss all
that because I have you missed okay
I missed all that because I went
the United States oh yeah and there you
were practicing exchange of information
you were trying to equalize equalize the
information what was this driven by
communism yeah yeah what happened was I
began to take information out of
Advanced Micro Devices the company I
worked for
they made chips and they still make
chips and that information the process
information how to make a chip what
machines are used the designs of the
machines the whole process essentially
the whole you know the whole store went
to Cuba to Fidel Castro over a period of
12 I think about 11 years we just kept
giving information to the Cuban
government the Cuban government would
get that information to the Soviet Union
oh you work you were directly involved I
didn't know that this exchange of
information was to come in his
government you're taking things at
another level they'll get because when I
was a teenager when I was a teenager my
dream was to steal the the recipe for
moose sausages from the butcher at my
village and I was like it's and it's
unjust that such good sausages can only
be produced by this man and one day was
about to die and I called them and I
said I want your sausage received for
moose sausages if you die it's going to
get out of the planet Earth and no one
will ever get it and this [ __ ] died
with the recipe but you you didn't let
that you didn't let the butcher die you
pumped the information out of him and
you spread it to him coming his
government's Wow
you know giving information through
their embassies essentially that what
they would do they would send a man over
my controller my handler named his fake
name was Julio Rosa and later on we
found out his real name but you know we
would meet him at the border towns of
Mexico with Texas I
in Texas in Austin Texas at the time so
we would cross the border with my wife
and with our car and in the trunk of my
car would carry all the stuff that I had
copped across the border
give it to who Leon and he would take it
to the embassy the embassy would you
know package it and then ship it you
know by diplomatic courier to the Cuba
and you know then later on Fidel Castro
invited my wife and myself to - he
invited us to Cuba we went there we met
her three times and and we were taken to
the place where they had all this
information which was in a little video
on the western side of the island when
we went there I couldn't believe there
was a whole room full of this stuff I
mean I gave him so much stuff that's
unbelievable they had like three or four
people there who were translating all
this stuff I think into Spanish for one
but they I think they were also
translating into Russian but I'm not so
sure about that part they eventually
give this information to the KGB guy his
name was critical one of the guys who
later tries to overthrow Gorbachev and
you know a party of Cubans went down and
they were uh they were very welcomed by
the KGB who thanked them and they said
yeah that they have really you know had
a big coup in penetrating us technology
you know the way they would want you
know because Russia was very far more
Soviet Union was very far behind on
technology and in several aspects and
chip technology was important because it
ran the missiles and so on so you know
with with that they they caught up a
little you know to the Americans so what
years are we talking about
well we're talking about 1980 to 1992 so
the so it was part of the buildup in the
Cold War yeah yeah yeah the Cold War you
can say almost came to an end 1989 but
that's when you get stuff you working
then
bigot took a pause of his work and the
Cold War in 1989 the Soviet bloc
collapse you know Germany collide East
Germany collapse etc and and what's
happening is that Cuba ran into trouble
with Gorbachev Gorbachev and was not
going to help or subsidize Cuba anymore
and Fidel Castro was absolutely you know
pissed about that and but I was still
helping the Cubans
okay and they were not giving the
information to Russia until you know
they patched up their differences well
it turns out that you know then they had
what was his name I can't remember the
guy who replaced Gorbachev now Yeltsin
Boris Yeltsin and you know the thing
progressed to what we have today over
there you know the Soviet Union
collapsed all the provinces turned into
separate countries and Russia's what it
is today but the point is that you know
I was helping the Cubans up to 1992 and
after that you know I went to the CIA
and turned myself in and that's just
like the Cubans Toby I thought they were
gonna put you in prison I know the CIA
began working so this turning yourself
in what motivated this well that's a
little weird story I was in Cuba and I
may I befriended some of the
intelligence officers and in fact one of
the intelligence officers is the guy
they traded in the days of Obama that
they were headed for Alan Gross his name
was Rolando San Refugio
we called him Rodney and rody went to
prison for 20 years he Cuba and he's he
was in there for 20 years he was traded
by Obama that's the guy that they traded
for Alan Gross and he's the guy that
worked with me and they put him in
prison because of me that's how he had
been in prison hmm and and you know when
when I befriended these guys they told
me look we want to overthrow the Cuban
government and I just couldn't believe
it but that's you know that's the
story they told me I believed it and
they told me look we want you to go to
the CIA or we're gonna give you
information to give the CIA and we want
to work with the CIA in secret to see if
we can overthrow the Cuban government
and since I was you know by that time I
was completely disillusioned with Cuba
with communism at UITs Pacific me I
decided to turn myself in against the
advice of my wife she objected like that
at all but I went there I went to the
CIA building in Langley and and I told
him the story and 45 days later the FBI
came to my house and from that time on
we worked for like two years and so you
ended up being charged and did you spend
time in jail how did that work well what
happened was that I started working at
Intel with the knowledge of the FBI of
course they knew about it but they never
told Intel and so Intel found out in a
weird way about me turns out that the
head of the security of AMD his name was
Pete Costner you'll see the pictures
there I sent you and Pete Costner put an
ad in the in the net and it was like a
wanted poster think of it that way I
don't know how they did it but he put
some kind of a wanted poster on me at
the semiconductor Association in
California I'm looking at the pictures
you sent me and I see a fast driver
license from California Wow you were one
of these international agents yeah go
ahead
I just want to show you where let's see
if I can get the picture okay give me
one second here yeah it's the picture
number four all right number four look
at picture number four and that is you
can see there the
dirty managers of intel and AMD steve
lund is the guy from Intel and Pete
Costner's a guy from AMD and what Pete
Costner did he put in like a wanted
poster at the semiconductor Association
and Steve lund who had just entered
Intel as a security chief he found out
about that and he discovered that I was
working for him now and so he contacted
the FBI and the FBI
you know the guys on the side there the
FBI guys Tim King and Bob Baker David
Johnson these guys there and he notified
them and and so you know the appeal was
the FBI gonna tell ya we know and so
what Intel did was Steve man he
approached me and he says look we need
for you to cooperate in an internal
investigation and it turns out the
internal investigation was an external
one they wanted really information on
what I did at AMD now man they said if I
didn't cooperate since I signed a
confidentiality agreement if I didn't
cooperate with them then what would
happen is they would have to fire they
would have to pull my badge well I was
put between the sword in the wall you
know and so at that moment in time I
filmed the technology of any of Intel
what I did is I I was living in Arizona
at the time and I got into the Intel
database in Albuquerque New Mexico film
all the specs for the top of the line
the state-of-the-art chip which was the
Pentium at the time and I took all this
information to Argentina and sold it to
the Chinese in Europe but then I seen
your picture there's a camera in the
oven is this some sort of before the
times cameras get smaller and that was
the most secret you could get that's it
that's a secret camera before
miniaturization I still get that this
you're gonna have to show it where your
neck is if you want to be in the frame
yeah yeah we can say if you can see that
that's a little recorder it's got the
what is called the pickup cable okay I
don't know if you can see this yeah pick
up cable there that's what the gangster
farms in your belt and then he kills you
on the receiver are you serious Wow
this is this is why you're typing from
the 80s yeah yeah yeah holy [ __ ] and
here's another see this is a pen that's
got a it's a cable it's a pen that's got
a cable to it and you would put it here
and you know you'd put it into the
review put the end you know the plug in
the nd quarter
and anyone who talked with you you were
recording you have a whole bat man cave
of equipment now during out this time
you're getting paid directly in Bitcoin
or what no no by the Cubans I would
never paid I did that for ideological
reasons only be by large I'm believing
now oh my god the Communists always does
the work for free yeah you remember that
when you're in that state of mind you're
a communist you're a fanatic communist
you do it for the heart you do it for
the mind you don't do it for the puck
and it's very hard for people to believe
that today but yeah that's that's the
state of my niche yeah well you're
hypnotized and so with the Cubans for
10-12 years I did it completely free no
money in their net not at all for the
Chinese and the Iranians as
different story I had to do something
different because I was getting back at
Intel that was those those with
adventures they had no reason to fire me
because up to that point I had done
nothing to Intel they didn't want any
information so that AMD can take me you
know the court that did that one
did I hear the word uranium and what's
yourself Chinese uranium no you don't
know no no okay
I misunderstood so Iran Iran okay
Chinese and Iran I went to their
embassies and talk to their counsels and
about a month later they had people from
their countries engineers come over and
we met at restaurants and I you know I
had given the information the cassettes
which I had recorded and I put them up
to date verbally on what the cassette
you know I complimented their education
you know personally uh-huh now when you
look at all this is that a common
situation for the International CIA
agents to be so much on their own
to be subject to extortion to be subject
to reversal by their own team and to be
not sure if they're in the team of Intel
or if the Intel is investigating on them
are there many US agents out there that
were operating a little bit in that gray
area between being kind of corporate
mercenaries and agents of the true US
governments I can only tell you what Jim
King Tom he FBI agent who handled my
case and he said once he told me he says
look I said you know in fact I haven't
recorded I got it on tape
and he said the following he said we
don't care what these guys are referring
to the Cubans right you don't care what
their motivation is you don't care if
it's ideological you know they didn't
care about that they said once we get to
them will turn on morale we we have the
we have a means to turn them around and
I think that applies to any agent I mean
imagine American agent
and he's in Russia or in China and you
know they approach him and they give him
a good deal you know one that they can
refuse or maybe they got him on the spot
maybe they found him sleeping with
someone he wasn't supposed to that kind
of li and so and so they begin to bribe
him they begin to extort him and they
could be you know using that guy against
his own cover so that that does happen
not very frequently but it could happen
sir now looking back at this trade of
information that you did do you regret
it do you think our deal are you still
in the mood of spreading information do
you have a mentality of free flow of
information like the matrix Joe Rogan
style trip in some other dimension or do
you regret well first of all I don't
regret what I did because I did it at a
time I had a certain mentality and I
don't have that mentality anymore so I
did what I did when I did it and I don't
do that anymore in physics and you
mentioned being disillusioned with the
dream of communism what did you
understand at some point in your life
that made you say communism doesn't work
and you know we would meet in hotels and
restaurants and so on tako a while and
we would talk about politics we would
talk about the situation in Cuba and the
Soviet Union that kind of thing and over
time over the years you know we're
talking about 1112 years you know a lot
of things I didn't like about what I was
hearing you know here were all these
potatoes as they were called a PITA
they're still called like just like that
people who go with a little raft from
Cuba and just escape to Miami or
whatever and and I said what is it video
just let them go you know freedom they
want to go go and you said that to cast
her not why I said that to the handlers
you
and we just discussed politics
philosophy that Kenneth E and I said
where does he just let him go you know
they want to leave the country let him
go and you know their argument was well
you know it's the United States who is
you know fomenting just encouraging
people to leave the island for
propaganda purposes so they had this
issue and you know I did like the idea
that they tailed freedom same for the
Soviet Union
so when Gorbachev came to power and he
said you know glasnost that is throwing
this kind of thing you know a little
more freedom I said well this is the
right guy this guy's got this guy's got
the right attitude because you know it's
got to liberalise you know a little bit
you know the the type news that the
communist government has over its people
and so when I go to Cuba first really
the first stop was Czechoslovakia at the
time you know and that was my first time
I was came to a communist country and
the first thing you notice about a
communist countries they have no food
they have a big trouble getting food out
pop of the tape you know for some reason
and you know we noticed that he media
and when we went to Cuba we saw more of
the same thing you know food was a
problem and we're really hurt it was not
so much the food because we knew in
advance that you was a poor country you
can't expect a banana republic to you
know put caviar on the table for
everyone and it turns out that you go
there and you see privilege that's
that's the one that trick that's when
that really got me because I said hold
it you got people who belong to the
Communist Party and you know they're
you're affiliated with the government
and they have all these perks all these
privileges that the common man on the
street does not have and you see that
you say well look you know and then
another thing you see is prostitutes
you see prostitutes you know trying to
make a living on the streets and they
don't do it for money that's the worst
part they do restitutive live State they
do it for lipstick you know you go I
said you can have them you know girls in
Havana and well because you know they
absolutely cray
cosmetics you can cut you can bribe the
entire country with cosmetics right and
that's what we did with my wife we
bought a whole bunch of cosmetics and
took it to Cuba to friends and family
there my wife her father is Cuban and so
we took it to the family and they the
women just went nuts they they
absolutely went out of their minds with
all the cosmetics we took down here this
from someone who came to the USSR I had
heard that they were bringing jeans and
jeans were extremely prized in the USSR
because it was the only way to get them
was to talk to an American tourists yeah
they crave all these things that they
don't have food things you know material
things especially right and that was a
big problem and and but then within that
society you see privilege you see people
who haven't people who don't and the
people who haven't it turns out you know
they belong to the Communist Party so
you know that's that's when you say well
is this what I'm fighting for for free I
was doing it for free so I'm saying is
look what I'm fighting for is this what
Fidel Castro did the Revolution
overthrow Batista we're against humanity
stop to bring the same thing and and
something else that you notice when you
go to Cuba you see this apartheid
between Cubans and human beings there's
a difference between them you go to a
restaurant and the Cubans are on one
side and the foreigners are on the other
side they can't mix but if a Cuban
brings a foreigner as a friend to eat to
the Union fights them to the restaurant
the foreigner has to pay you see all you
see a lot of that stuff and it just it's
just tremendous it bothers me a lot you
know but and so you see all this WC
privilege you see that the things don't
work as you would think of social this
country should work and then you know at
one point you to say no the helpers but
in another fun too you say hi I hear
these communist countries were not the
proper communist system there is some
ideal to be reached that could be
reached I mean
do you see what I mean I mean we have a
question on this it's the pepper who
says why do communists always think MA
this time will be different
are they genuinely stupid is that what
you're telling us that you typically
you're not you're not disillusioned with
the idea of communism but that you don't
like their implementation there's so
many aspects to it the first aspect is
that you no no no revolution the French
Revolution the peasant revolt in England
you know these all these movement the
Russian Revolution all these movements
people have idealist in their groups in
this grassroots movement right and they
go out there with pick pitch and forks
and pitchforks and he try to overthrow
the government right and so if there is
a numerous enough and they're lucky
enough they do overthrow the government
what happens next well what happens next
is someone takes over the government
becomes the new king and you still have
a pyramid you never get rid of a pyramid
so I think it's an illusion
you know the very lutherie very
idealistic to think that any government
can be overthrown and the workers are
gonna take over which is what Marx
essentially suggested you know the
dictatorship of the proletariat you just
impose a workers society where we're all
equal there's got to be a dictatorship
because you have to control property
that sort of thing but it turns out that
the guys who take over power look at
what happened in pure look at what
happened and so you know they know
what's happening still in North Korea
you still have the pyramid you have one
guy at the table who's got a limousine
and and a lot of people on the bottom
that don't have it and so you never get
rid of that and so I don't think so so
it's a nice ideal to think that you know
humans can all be equal to each
according to his needs from each
according to his ability that sort of
equality it never happened never will it
doesn't even happen in the plant world
let alone in the animal world you know I
got plants I grow plants and you see one
plant grow big and the other little guy
next to it you know
and he gets less Sun the other guy gets
all the you know all the this Sun you
know yes yeah so so one grows big and
the other one grows small even within a
plant one leaf is big one leaf is small
so you always see hierarchy you never
see equality across the board I don't
think it ever happened mother nature
never intended it you know so I had this
illusion about humans living in peace
and all being equal there's no know you
know like John Lowe you know imagine all
the people living in this world etc it
never happened never will it never will
because you know you have to have this
pyramid structure in the animal and
plant world I don't think I mother
nature made any provisions for equality
no equality doesn't make sense a priori
unless there is an advantage and sharing
and there is rarely in evolution now you
seem to have been involved in
technological stuff mostly technological
information and in relation to the
communist governments but we know that
there are other international networks
I'm thinking for example of what was
established around Jeff Epstein recently
and discovered recently and I'm thinking
also about the networks of influence of
Israel have you seen these things
develop or were you just in your come in
this world and you didn't see that no I
didn't see a lot of that because you
know again I'm I was focused on what I
was doing I think I was pretty good at
it because we were successfully I don't
know if they would have ever discovered
us you know the only reason they
discovered us is I turned myself in had
no idea I was even exist and so you know
I was very focused in what I was doing
so you know a lot of these things I mean
there's a lot of things going on in the
world you I can't be in touch with
everything but all I can tell you is uh
yeah we were successful it was a period
of my life that's left behind a long
time ago it was adventurous
it was very nice you know the Cubans
made passports
we we went with fake passports from
country to country you know it was a lot
of fun it was Adventures was nice and
again we did it mainly for ideological
reasons and we were in a position to do
so and the sales of that when you when
you're there is what am i doing all this
for now that's when you start asking
questions when I see you and miss out
these crimes I'm thinking for the rest
of your life you don't plan traveling
right
I travel gossip are you travelling I
mean I thought that when you were
admitting that many crimes on the
public's face that you couldn't go in
much places that they would catch you
and they would they would take your
admission as evidence I'm at peace with
everyone I don't know maybe the Cubans
might still want to do something to me
but I doubt it
you know with the Yanks I'm at peace you
know they put me in prison for three
years but you know I have no I'm not in
touch with them or anything and they're
not interested in me as far as I know so
there's any problem I don't theory I'm
not looking over my shoulder you know
well now are you following the current
political situation when you see the
Democrat Party and as abattoir on Andrew
Young are you tempted by the universal
basic income of Andrew Young as they
form of semi communism humans oh yeah
you believe that we're headed toward
extinction civil war yeah where I think
if we're at the doorstep of our
extinction because I think the global
economy is going to collapse once it
collapses no one produces food or
distributes foods to the cities that's
what I think's gonna happen
that's a mass extinction 8 million
people die in a matter of weeks I mean
the food system is quite reliable and
distant countries I mean on the company
side because of money only because of
money
I mean disappears
when money disappears there's no more
food I think you've been hanging out too
much downtown because I know everybody
just right two hours from any big city
and what you see is a network of people
essentially trading tomatoes for
potatoes for lumber for the winter and
they could they could make an
abstraction of money to some extent it's
quite simple capture the whole thing the
whole thing is driven by money in the
end without money there is no food no
one produces food without money well
there is still something like a
communist in you bill get you you are
intimately afraid of capitalism the way
Karl Marx was just that for several
reasons were at the end of the line one
is we've lost our genetic diversity so
we can't go very long from a biological
standpoint the other one is our
population pyramid has started
overturning in 1963 steadily year after
year we have fewer but it's at birth
rates ok year after year the birth rate
is falling the United Nations
demographers predict that if everything
continues as it's going so grinds been
going on for the last 50 years by
mid-century
we reached zero population growth one
person is born one person decides you
know there's no increase in population
on the planet so those things are in the
background but I'm saying that's that
one's going to cause our extension our
extinction is gonna be caused because
money will be no more the global economy
will collapse it can't grow forever
especially a populations decline money
is there as long as people need a unit
to trade right money is there because we
created this abstraction called money we
had all kinds of money throughout
history we had bartering we went the
gold we went the paper and now we're in
numbers and a computer that's that's
what Bill Gates is worth he's worth
whatever he's got whatever number he's
got in a computer that's it we're fields
dodging and B's we breached Bitcoin
Bitcoin this summer another electronic
coin but the point here is that these
are these are this is money but money is
an abstraction money has no intrinsic
value and the only thing that keeps the
entire system in the world on the planet
going is money if God wants the Creole
man tomorrow all he's got to do somehow
you raise all the money in the world
right here Aizaz all the money
who's gonna wet agricultural corporation
which produces at least 50% of the food
on the planet what record your
corporation is gonna produce food
without any money I mean I know a couple
of guys would continue producing two
methyls as long as the guy who makes the
lumber brings them lumber yeah you know
one thing is to produce food for
yourself which is not even possible so
easy today especially not in your
apartment everybody's got an apartment
these days most of them live in the city
so most of the people would die oh yeah
but nobody's got a farm
it's the corporations which have farms
today and and in fact I think one of the
reasons Trump has no problem with what's
going on with the China for example is
that he doesn't care if the little
farmer loses his farm and goes to the
cities because he's going to buy it the
corporation and as long as the big
corporations buy out their farms he
doesn't care if a lot of farmers lose
their farms you know individual farmers
lose their farms you know to the city
that's happened in history many times so
I don't think that's why I don't think
they care they subsidize them with some
money
whoever can live can live that guy who
loses his farm because he can't pay the
mortgage or bond that you got from the
bank he loses his farm they don't care
because the fun is taken by a big
corporation which now has economies of
scale applied to it and to proves
probably more efficiently and cheaper
whatever they're producing and so they
don't care but my point is that
agricultural corporations produce the
majority of food they don't go out there
and barter and believe me they do it for
money only no money no food no well let
me tell you that
I'm personally very enthusiastic out the
future you describe because something
tells me that my personality is more
adjusted to a zombie apocalypse and that
I would be better in a shotgun shooting
waves of zombie humans coming at me than
just just a youtuber with IDs Fernando
Kevin says Bill did what he did before
rogue came to town that's one question I
add the transition between that part of
your life where you were doing out the
center and electronics to the rope
theory how did that happen was this a
progression the de rope came
progressively in your mind or was it
just like a big roll of rope just
dropping into your brain well the first
thing I was in prison when I developed
the rope model it came out of the issue
with God nothing to do with physics
really to start out with you know I come
from a very strong atheist background my
family was atheist they were militant
atheists my we were living in Baltimore
when the what's-her-name
Madalyn Murray O'Hair I don't know if
you heard about her she's the founder of
American Atheists there's a friend of
ours he would come to our house and she
recruited by my father and mother and we
joined her organization very early when
she was just starting out and so we were
we always talked about you know religion
at home politics and religion and we
talked about the Bible we were very
well-versed in Christianity and thought
the Bible and all that kind of stuff but
from the other point of view so when I
go to prison you know I knew my Bible I
knew it I read it three times completely
you know so so I knew my Bible very well
and you find all these guys who
committed crimes out there you know they
do primarily drugs they come in there
and suddenly they find God in prison you
know they're they become born-again
Christians or porygon Islamists and so
ahead and talks with these guys and of
course I found out that they didn't even
know their own books and they never read
the Bible they never read so you know we
went you wanted a party-pooper in prison
shutting down
the the awakened Ness of these men who
to the truth of Jesus I can tell and so
you know we had discussions and they
said well prove to me that God does not
exist and so I said oh okay and I said
I'm gonna find a good answer for this
and that's when I started looking into
physics and when I look in physics I
find black holes big bang and all this
nonsense that I hear about time dilation
going back and kill your grandfather and
you know all this nonsense that they
have out there and I said no this is
forget about religion this is religion
this is true religion and that's when I
started investing you guys well look if
I'm a rational guy how come I cannot
rationalize how this universe works I
should be able to know what light is
what gravity is what magnetism is what
electricity I should be able to explain
in a rational manner that's when I
started researching and after about a
year and a half I came up with the idea
of the Rope you know the Rope torsion
along the Thomas award says this guy's
insight on plants iraqis is very
perceptive
reminds me of jordan peterson don't hate
my take on this jf well that that's a
very nice compliment bill get you may be
on your way to becoming a millionaire if
you have these jordan peterson qualities
thomas award says the guest believes in
the coming economic collapse jf believes
we will be turned into a component of a
more advanced genetic form as
mitochondria and chloroplasts were all I
know is something is coming
Nietzsche modernist says vive General
Pinochet vive general Stroessner free
recapture rides wow that is that is
quite something
ka says bill was your needle experiment
replicated what the needle
Alex Perl oh it's a simple experiment
that anyone can do he's talking about
the double slit experiment and you don't
need double slits and I guess people in
the Universities never figured that out
turns out that the slit experiment was
performed originally by Grimaldi and
later on by Newton and he put a hair
he put a hair and he shone a light
through the hair he created the fringes
and then Thomas Young repeats the
experiment century later in 1800 and he
doesn't put the double slit but the
third experiment that Thomas Young does
is with a hair also heat that's why I
called the Newton you know the Newton
hair experiment I don't consider it my
not consider it Newton's and if you put
a needle in front of a laser pointer
very simple experiment just put the
needle in a cork you know just stick it
in a cork put it there
shine the laser pointer to it and you'll
see the fringes on the on the screen and
you'll see what is that what we say
somewhere hope very simply what you see
is that the interference pattern or the
slit and the question is you can't do
that with particles or waves you can't
do it the only way with a rope with a
rope you can explain it but you can't
explain that with with part no way
so the reason experiment like you know
let me show you something real quick
yeah let's say that's the needle that's
my beer bottle okay and the particle
will hit will hit here and will hit here
right
and he'll bounce and go outwards it'll
never bounce against the edge and go
inwards to interfere with the other part
yeah so you can't do it with particles
but then you kill with away because all
the atoms are interconnected with the
rope so you can do with a rope you can't
particles or ways but but but what you
said does annihilate the possibility of
a particle but then what about a wave a
wave could go around the bottle of beer
Oh only if it's like a water wave and
the question is what kind of wave are we
talking about what is this way
there's no physical object called the
wave you gotta identify the object that
is wavy what is waving they say it's
particle so we're back to particles wow
I mean what is water particles began
comes on the public says he comes on the
picnic space once again and I am deaf
being more and more convinced that
particles don't exist but I have not
discarded waves yet the waves are
particles what is wavy they say it's
particles
what is the ether particles oh yeah yeah
you're yeah this whole idea that a wave
needs to be in something right it's a
crystal field a quantum field would that
work you can have a wave of quantum
fields well what is a field please
identify what a field is they never
defined a word field and as you know
it's the field that's why I'm ready so
what's a field what's energy what is a
firecracker 80 no they're spirits it's
like saying the spirit wait a vibrate so
what do you mean by spirit well it's you
know it's the spirit you know what
spirit did right that's all they say
what is a field what is energy these
words have never been defined Frank the
same as an object
Frank desert has King Bill how exactly
were you recruited by government agents
through academia or political networking
no no no I was not recruited I went to
the amphitheater and presented myself
III gave a show I gave him a little show
to the console you know so he listened
to me and said this guy is offering me
technology and that's how it work and
you know a few months later they they
sent someone to my house in Sunnyvale
California where I live and that's when
they said look we need for you to go to
Mexico and we went there with my wife
and we met our handler from there we
started work you you went to an embassy
located in the u.s. no no no the
another second one well no I went to
twice the first guy didn't do anything
the second guy went to the intersection
of the the Cuban interest section which
was located inside the Czechoslovakian
embassy in Washington DC so we went to
Washington DC with a whole bunch of
material wafers manuals all kind of
stuff and I gave a show to the I don't
know if he was a console what he was but
he was the head of the embassy or the
interest section I gave a presentation
to him he liked the idea and six months
later they sent someone to my house in
Sunnyvale and they said look the Cuban
government wants you to go to Mexico and
that's what we did we went to Mexico we
met with their representatives now bill
gayde I was married three times and all
of my wives leave me for drinking too
much Diet Coke or for sleeping at every
year instead of 10 p.m. how the heck did
you have a wife through this that
followed you on all these international
adventures and didn't leave you Franco
services thanks bill for your answer I
will be headed toward covering some news
solo but it was great hearing your story
bill was there anything else you wanted
to discuss tonight absolutely thank you
so much for coming tonight what a story
I didn't expect this I was like today I
was like okay I need to prepare a
discussion about communism all I knew
was bill gayde is going to come and he's
going to talk to you about communism and
I was like okay let's talk about how
common ism is bad I was prepared to make
some political arguments but he comes
with this freaking crazy story oh my god
how
amazing is it to be speaking again with
the Gade Wow